mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur und
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
wissen sie was ich scheiß auf den
wohlstand
was geschieht wenn eine performerin wie
lara stoll plötzlich in sich geht und
ein buch schreibt
[Musik]
was geschieht wenn menschen gemeinsam
ein buch lesen und darüber sprechen ist
wirklich dreist gemacht und wird für die
woche von neuem wengen mit sind mit der
gruppe c trifft auf seine reiske wir
ergründen die lust auf bücher und die
freude am lesen
[Musik]
wir kommen auf dem kulturplatz ja heute
wollen wir ergründen weshalb das lesen
noch immer glücklich macht und unsere
lebensqualität ganz konkret steigern
kann station dafür machen wir in
winterthur denn das grösste schweizer
literatur festival zürich liest ist
dieser tage auch hier präsent das große
programm mit über 200 lesungen findet im
ganzen kanton stadt ja was macht ihn aus
sind zauber des lesens und des vorlesens
dazu gleich mehr hier aus dem
winterthurer kulturcafé kohlmeier
die slam poetin lara stoll ist ein
bühnentier par excellence comedy slam
poetry musik oder schauspiel ganz egal
die stoll kannst nun lag lara schon ihr
erstes buch vor jetzt jetzt vielleicht
zur stillen schreiberin wir glauben kaum
wir haben sie getroffen
wenn ich den staubsauger nach dem
gebrauch wieder verstauen will da brauch
ich breite messer und eine
darmspiegelung wegen stressbedingten
reinste
lara stoll still von wegen die
herausforderungen des alltags bringen
das thurgauer bühnentier nach wie vor in
rage
[Musik]
auf die tube drückt sie auch im
aktuellen programm gipfel der freude den
furor niederschreiben und auf die bühne
bringen stolz lebenselixier
aber hallo
das ist das erste mal dass es mit pak
choi und park gegeben ich bin als kind
schon ganz unwichtige mensch xiii und
nette mit klasse wenn es nicht
funktioniert und ich bin ja nicht der
einzige person wo im alltag meistens
stammt von jürgen trittin gelten liegt
einen geldsegen erhofft sich die 34
jährige jetzt mit ihrem ersten buch die
idee drängte schon lange doch erst der
korona shutdown verschaffte die nötige
muße
auch schwarz auf weiß ist stoll ein
offenes buch sie schreibt über
persönliche abgründe aufreger über
alkohol drogen und phobien und das
gewohnt groteske
einzug gehalten haben erprobte
pointendichte texte wie das verstauen
des staubsaugers aber auch extra fürs
debüt verfasste geschichten
geschrieben die
sache
ich mich vertiefen drehen wo wurden
vielleicht gott beim bmw sind aber
womöglich wichtig sind dass ich dir mach
erzählen ohne dass es ganz reaktion beim
publikum bucht wählen eine periode
flache
stolz texte sammlung birgt auch poesie
mein herz du sollst nicht verzagen ich
lege deine wunden ordentlich und lang
rauch und saufen uhr das herz bleibt
bewirbt war denn ich lecke deine wunden
ordentlich und lang
[Musik]
geschrieben hat stoll schon als kind die
schule habe ihr die freude am texten
zwar vorübergehend versaut doch schon
mit 18 mischte sie die slam poetry
männerdomäne auf um kurz darauf mit
höchster ps-zahl durchzustarten
in der fronthydraulik wäre
[Musik]
bestimmt keine frauen probleme mehr
seither lässt stolz ich nicht mehr klein
kriegen feiert erfolge räumt preis und
preis ab
da kleine party
fieber duden ich vermisse dich weißt du
nicht mehr da bist kann ich nicht mehr
schreiben um 20.05 titel den sie die 54
1238 folge von der alte ratzeburg geht's
am schreiben wird stoll rastlos auf der
suche nach dem quell der lust und dem
ideen fluss chao phraya voraus blatt
unter der unten schon gut also ich muss
es wirklich noch liter pro kasten jahre
aufschieben lust auf staunen lassen
stolz rezept
[Musik]
und über
projekte um eine sache zu vertagen gibt
es zuhauf
nebst haushalt film schauspiel ich doch
droht und musik
wenn immer möglich in eigenregie
[Musik]
die kooperation mit einem verlag sei
nicht einfach gewesen gesteht die
freiheitsliebende vertreterin der
generation y
relativ verwöhnt aufgewachsen
verhätschelt worden und im schlepptau
wohlstandsgesellschaft die und hat so
groß sie träumen oder und und schafft es
aber nicht den briefkasten regelmäßig
oder eine telefonnummer
selber im weg findet dass das irgendwie
genau lustig und tragisch gleichzeitig
und um das genaue ein buch und das ist
die sind für mich auch das argument
kapitalismus mit so einem scheiß
vorstand wissen sie was ich scheiß auf
den wohlstand
[Musik]
hallo plötzlich vertritt nun
betrieben sie sind engagiert die
organisation vor ort der gespräche
verlasse den winter zu treffen sie heute
aus grob präsident info der literarische
vereinigung winterthur also wäre nicht
sie sind kompetent beurteilen was man
daraus macht der zauber zu lassen das
muss jeder für sich beantworten ich sehe
einfach das ist schon mal eine gute buch
aufwand einfach wenn sie gute geschichte
gut erzählt wird da muss natürlich einen
guten
blick auf die bühne
und man muss das
kurzfristig also nicht elend lang las
passagen sondern wirklich gute gespräche
und ich mir meistens sind die autorinnen
und autoren sehr originell mainz also
die erschaffer der ganze wald und von
der sache
für mich ausmacht und doch gibt es ja
wahrscheinlich um die sei weniger action
verspricht aus einem mann show bühne wo
liest und andre fuhr los man hat das
bild für die klassische master class
aber das muss gar nicht immer sie nach
outlook
word is broken bärtige bis machen
womit podcast all solid und
offensichtliches produkt ist zu hause
lernen und sind für die lav zu sich
holen dann im schlafzimmer oder
wohnzimmer aber gibt es dauernd
entwicklungsstopp fehler wenn sie sagen
machen lasse bereich passiert halt ist
ja es gibt viele autorinnen und autoren
wo mittlerweile wirklich mit dem musiker
fest und will dass ich es bühne element
oder es hat den dramaturgischen strandet
ihnen und musiker dazu gehört oder rosa
bereits drei
wochen singen die nachwende auch ein
vielleicht auch lust auf das kindliche
bedürfnisse
zählt über klassik als auch mal gemacht
ja ich glaube schon also das waren
gläubiger mitbürger kaká brachte
bedienen sind und
schluss am einkaufszentrum einfache
der eskapismus also riesig in eine
andere welt ihnen danken und auch das
hat er auch sehr oft bis extrem lehrerin
baht etwa die zum beispiel also
verschiedene sachen lernt durch lose
sogar 30 der laster in zukunft ich hoffe
wieder zurück vom stream ist analoge sie
reitet gerne auf heiko christians oder
das wohnzimmer aber sichere als solches
wird es mit uns sterben
bei lesungen gilt ja normalerweise die
regel ein mensch liest und alle anderen
hören zu nun gibt es aber auch die idee
des gemeinsamen lesens das in
großbritannien bereits sehr populär ist
schert reading entspricht einem grossen
bedürfnis und kann wahre wunder wirken
nun bringen drei frauen diese idee des
gemeinsamen lesens nach basel
das lesen bildet ist eine binsenweisheit
auch das lesen die grundlage ist für
kultur für fortschritt für alles
doch lesen kann mehr kann befreien
entführen aus der einsamkeit
lesend erkundet mann und frau fremde
welten
lesen kann wie ein spiegel sein in dem
man sich neu betrachtet neuer kennt
[Musik]
viel einfacher kunden einfach mit mit
buchfiguren nicht umgehen
der text macht der friede small eva
ansturm der türe auf und das ist einfach
wunderbar
[Musik]
diese schöne momente die ich mit mit
büchern erleben durfte dass das für mich
ganz wichtig in meiner biografie
wie sehr lesen neue türen öffnen kann
diese erfahrung wollen katja schnitzer
beatrice bürki und alexandra stäheli mit
anderen teilen hier in basel
praktizieren sie schert reading was
bedeutet in einer gruppe gemeinsam zu
lesen und über das lesen und nachdenken
die welt und sich selbst neu zu
entdecken es ist oft relativ schnell
dass die teilnehmer sich auch öffnen und
das sind aufseher magische momente und
er hat es ist wirklich oft sehr gehören
literatur als lebenshilfe als brücke um
miteinander ins gespräch zu kommen die
gruppe in basel liest einen text von
hermann hesse das nacht vom auge
dann überfällt mich für augenblicke
wieder der das namenlose
gierige entzücken des no kinder
empfinden können
nach dem lesen wird frei assoziiert was
löste text aus das könnte bedeuten
wenn ich alt werde denn die ich kenne
dann erinnere ich an meine kindheit
in einer anderen
stadt reading gemeinsam lesen was so
einfach klingt funktioniert nach einer
ausgeklügelten methode die vor etwa zehn
jahren in großbritannien entwickelt
wurde
inzwischen lesen dort über 10.000
menschen in mehr als 700 gruppen unter
dem dach der organisation der wieder
von hier aus aus dem karl des turms park
in liverpool wird die revolution des
lesens ausgerufen hier werden
freiwillige ausgebildet die shared
reading gruppen initiieren und anleiten
sollen
jane davis hat der rieder gegründet und
die methode des shared reading
entwickelt
ich habe lange an der universität
erwachsene unterrichtet fast 20 jahre
lang
und in diesen klassen konnte ich öfter
menschen über einen längeren zeitraum
beobachten wie sie ich will nicht sagen
sich veränderten denn es ist keine
veränderung
aber sie realisierten etwas über sich
selbst über ihr leben und diese
erkenntnisse schienen wertvoll zu sein
[Musik]
das lesen einblicke bietet die wertvoll
sind das lesen trost bieten kann und den
blick auf die welt verändert das hat
john davis selbst erfahren sie wuchs auf
in liverpool unter schwierigen
verhältnissen
die mutter starb früh
literatur war etwas das ihr auswege
offenbarte
diese erfahrung wie lesen
lebensgeschichten verändern kann ließ
jane davis ihre erste lese gruppe
gründen in der die texte gemeinsam und
laut gelesen wurden
ich brachte auch gedichte mit in die
gruppe die wir dann laut vorgelesen
haben das war das erste mal dass ich
literatur laut mit einer gruppe gelesen
habe es war das gedicht crossing
und eine krankenschwester in der gruppe
fing an sehr zu weinen
[Musik]
sie sprach über diese zeilen aber
wenn die gezeiten bewegt erwachen zu
laut für wochenlangen klang dann kehrt
was grenzenlos in die tiefe zog nach
hause
und sie sprach über den tod ihres vaters
erinnerte sich wie er am fluss mercy
spazieren gegangen war dort steigt und
fällt die flut stark
es war sehr bewegend eine tiefgehende
persönliche reaktion auf ein gedicht das
hatte ich so intensiv noch nie zuvor
erlebt
es klingt so einfach man trifft sich und
liest gemeinsam tauscht sich aus
[Musik]
doch wie entsteht dieser eine moment das
schlüsselerlebnis wenn der text beim
lesen mehr wird als nur ein text und
sich in fragen verwandelt wenn gedanken
zu fliegen beginnen
herbst 2009 10 es ist die zeit vor der
ko witt 19 pandemie als man sich noch
ohne masken bewegen konnte damals
reisten beatrice bürki alexandra stäheli
und katja schnitzer nach liverpool um
sich bei der rieder als leiterinnen 1
reading gruppe weiterzubilden und zu
erfahren wie ein vertiefen das
miteinander in einer lese gruppe
angestoßen werden kann ich finde die
frage nach der us wahl vor der text
finde ich sehr wichtig und ich hoffe
dass mir da ein paar
gedanken vielleicht finden außer
diskussion einfach können wir mit texas
weil wir das ist wirklich das a und o
dass es funktioniert in der gruppe
[Musik]
ausbildung zum rieder lieder so nennen
sie hier die person die eine gruppe
anleitet moderiert die texte auswählt
und mit einigen wenigen fragen das
gespräch an stößt das auf das lesen
folgt
die leiterin einer gruppe muss in der
lage sein die beziehung die verbindung
zu knüpfen
wenn man diese beziehung nicht
herstellen kann macht es keinen sinn ein
shakespeare sonne zu nehmen weil die
leute dann denken das mochte ich noch
nicht das kann ich nicht es hängt viel
von den leitenden
fragen stellen und raum lassen für
assoziationen für erinnerungen das ist
die anspruchsvolle die sensible aufgabe
der leiter innen
eine atmosphäre schaffen in der die
literatur klingen kann und gleichzeitig
ein nachdenken beginnt über den text
über sich selbst
ihr könnt der literatur die leitung
überlassen aber ihr seid diejenigen die
unterstützen damit es besonders am
anfang nicht an der oberfläche bleibt
als shared reading leiterin misst er
herausfinden wie ihr die leute
unterstützen könnte freundlich ohne
druck damit etwas wachsen kann
was ist die funktion der texte sollen
sie etwas neues fremdes zeigen oder wie
ein spiegel das leben der lesenden
reflektieren
ich denke es ist wie ein spiegel aber
vielleicht auch wie ein fenster damit
man etwas von sich selbst erkennt aber
auch das andere
[Musik]
wer sich darauf einlässt ist mit dieser
erfahrung sehr beschäftigt
und die anderen leute in der gruppe
spüren dass da etwas gewaltiges
geschieht
eine erkenntnis geschieht
an den
und zwar nicht nur eine selbsterkenntnis
man erkennt etwas wahres
das größer ist als
[Musik]
sich selbst erkennen über den umweg des
lesens und dabei die umlaufbahn der
eigenen gedankenwelt verlassen um aus
dem teufelskreis der eigenen probleme
auszubrechen das macht er greding
interessant für die therapeutische
arbeit mit drogenabhängigen mit
alzheimer patientinnen mit gruppen in
gefängnissen in altersheimen
2009/10 besuchten wir mit amanda boston
eine lese gruppe in einer schmerzklinik
in liverpool
die menschen die in meiner gruppe kommen
leben alle mit erkrankungen die
chronische schmerzen verursachen
nach einer gewissen zeit beginnen sie
sichtbar sich zu entspannen und
ich denke diese entspannung ist auch
körpern
denn wenn die schmerzen kommen stehen
sie oft auf gehen umher oder man kann
sehen wie sie eine haltung einnehmen um
gegen den schmerz anzugreifen
einmal pro woche treffen sie sich im
moment lesen sie william shakespeares
stück was ihr wollt
[Musik]
wenn wir anfangen zu lesen mit
verteilten rollen vergisst man seinen
schmerz und er ist nicht mehr so schlimm
wie wenn man allein ist
welche wirkung lesen hat wie lesen die
empfindung von schmerz beeinflussen kann
damit beschäftigt sich der lese forscher
philip davis an der universität
liverpool
wenn sie unter chronischen schmerzen
leiden verändern sich im gehirn die
frontallappen so sehr dass die
patientinnen sogar wenn sie eigentlich
keine schmerzen haben aus reiner
gewohnheit schmerzempfinden diese
botschaft die beschäftigen ihr gehirn
die ganze zeit werden
[Musik]
ist das lesen nur eine momentane
ablenkung oder kann das lesen einen
prozess aktivieren der den kreislauf von
permanenter schmerzempfindung
durchbricht
muss das mit literarischen texten
geschehen wären einfache texte nicht
genauso geeignet
wir haben herausgefunden dass einfache
literatur oder ein zeitungsartikel nicht
ausreicht die texte waren zu geradlinig
zu einfach
es lenkte die menschen nicht von ihrem
andauernden quelle zwischen hals ab
mit literatur hingegen stellten wir fest
dass eine kraftvolle sprache in einem
emotional berührenden bereich eine
wirkung ausübt die die menschen
vorübergehend vergessen lässt dass sie
schmerzen haben
das lesen schafft einen freiraum und die
begegnung mit literatur sprengt den
teufelskreis der probleme und
konfrontiert die eigene
vorstellungskraft mit neuen perspektiven
mehr tricks bürki alexandra stäheli und
katja schnitzer haben nach ihrer
ausbildung in liverpool schärding in
asien etabliert
für sie ist das gemeinsame lesen mehr
als eine technik mehr als eine form von
innovativer sozialarbeit es ist etwas
ganz einfaches
weiß wo man macht und eine kmu wie die
woche von neuem wenn er mit einer gruppe
sicht recht auf seiner reise
durchs laut lesen und durch das was die
anderen dann sagen entsteht plötzlich
eine welt wenn man bekommt zugang zu der
welt sie wird plötzlich persönlich und
habe mit der eigenen zu tun das ist echt
schon ja es ist magisch
[Musik]
respekt vor mensch die überhaupt was
muss was ausmacht also vor vor denen
ludwig hama wo gemeinsam mit uns das
erfuhr die tragische figur
sich wie eine sparte und das interesse
für das was als menschen ausmacht
[Musik]
trotz den vielen erfolgreichen
literaturfestivals der buchmarkt steckt
seit jahren in der krise und trotzdem
gibt es noch immer immer wieder mutige
und auch übermütige läuteten einem
buchverlag gründen so wie etwa die junge
buchhändlerin schill erdmann naiv oder
visionär sehen sie dazu den beitrag
meiner kolleginnen von saf kultur
instagram im handy hochformat
[Musik]
letztlich
sprachen das muss ich gestehen dass ich
bin unheimlich stolz
das hat mich schon lange beschäftigt das
wenige frau produziert werden es weniger
autorin rezensierte den
modewochen rinal er damals immer wieder
das thema sind für mich und
verlagsgründer peter dauer und wieder zu
ganz nachgegangen will machen wir 1000
litern verlage und man braucht
und dann bin ich später antike
bezirksstadt fast 50 frauen von frauen
hat und
sehr angesprochen und das design von
burg
klassen ich mich sehr klar sie das
bedürfnis durch von der heutige
generation c klasse
die autoren haben ist der zitierte
text ist eine kirche von damals wieder
neu das hoch lag die hand denn
eigentlich alle ausnahmslos york seit
kam
und hat dann der gedanke
festgeschrieben
[Musik]
schaffe zusammen mit dem grafiker herren
die artemis
sie hat eigentlich die vision die ich
jetzt mehrere monate mit drei tonnen
aufs blatt braucht und dann sofort
also sieht es ja wir haben mit ihrer mit
natürlich auch fühlt und die literatur
für mich sprach alles und nannte sprach
spielt und sie
auffordert dann hat man mich eigentlich
für mich erledigt
das deutschsprachige autorinnen
publiziert werden
[Musik]
auch in basel sind dieser tagebücher
trumpf aktuell mit den buchwochen dann
ab dem vierten november das
internationale literaturfestival
buchbasel und schließlich die
preisverleihung des schweizer
buchpreises am 17 november das können
sie auch live per radio mitverfolgen
nächste woche geht es bei uns um
teilhabe in politik und kultur und
weshalb nicht jede stimme zählt gleich
jetzt geht's hier weiter auf sf1 mit der
sternstunde philosophie und dem
amerikanischen schriftsteller colson
whitehead zur frage wie die fiktion uns
befreien kann kommen sie gut durch die
woche tisch
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]